so warren buffett allows
uh dominique sue to shadow him for
several weeks the nfl star shared his
three key takeaways let's go into what
his key three takeaways worth spending
time with
d man d myth the legend this is a
business insider story so
the tampa bay buccaneer player said
every meeting was a hundred times more
valuable than an mba
the football player took three key
takeaways from the billionaire that have
underpinned his approach to business and
investing ever since those were to keep
things simple
that's number one focus on passions and
people that's number two
and always read learn and remain curious
about the world let me say that one more
time keep things simple
focus on passions and people always read
learn and remain curious about the world
the six foot four
305 pound line man also joked about his
stage arm wrestling matches
with buffing in recent years no matter
how many times we do it
i still can't beat him he tweeted must
be all that coca-cola
sue said in january he tries to catch up
with buffett every quarter and he's
gearing up for an investing career after
he retires from football and wants his
mentors
advice thoughts publicity stunt and it
doesn't work for me
okay really it's a dual publicity stunt
i am so
not interested in this and i'll tell you
why
okay in domic and sue what's he known
for he's known for being
probably the dirtiest nfl player of our
possibly okay
dirty okay nasty like he could have
ended careers he did not give a damn
he's stomping on people
sure hands and he was a very dirty
player now warren buffett is trying to
rehabilitate his image he's had a bad
year
if you ask me every time he's kind of a
lot i mean he
he's kind of getting branded as a guy
that you'd be surprised if he can make
his own oatmeal and get dressed in the
morning
right he's he's in his 90s so i think
this is a an opportunity
that he was thinking to rehabilitate his
image a little bit in the public eye
um and sue went to the university
university of nebraska so you're
wondering where did this connection even
come from
but why do we care that in dominican
sioux wants to be an investor
how is he even he's not even relevant as
a football player anymore let alone
someone
that's going to branch off and into the
uh investment world i think it was just
a it was an elaborate attempt for both
of these guys to grab some good
publicity
and then if you look at this i mean
warren buffett is a genius
okay he's probably one of the sharpest
people of the last hundred years i mean
you don't accidentally
do what he's done he's unbelievable but
all this stuff that
even his three key takeaways had no
substance to him they were so
basic and and obvious so i i don't think
this helped either of them i think if
you objectively look at it you can kind
of see through it
so i think if there's a publicity stunt
that warren buffett wants to do
if that's what you're going with you got
to pick someone better than in damage
and sue
like that ain't exactly a head like if
you're saying tom brady
you know shadowed endowment
warren buffett for the last few years
that'd be like holy [ __ ] there's a story
there this is like all right he's a
football player
i get it the nebraska uh um connection
right there
the the biggest thing here is like this
happened in 2010.
it was 11 years ago so i was like why
the hell is this even a story
you hit the nail on the head the
nebraska thing he was one of the best
players ever to come out on nebraska he
is one of the dirtiest players in the
nfl
i don't know what you know why he
couldn't clean up his act there
what i will say is i know you're saying
that i have that ha that warren
buffett's having a bad year i know you
made it fun that he can't make his own
oatmeal
however i think part of the problem with
warren buffett is
the the argument is that he might be a
little
out of touch these days with today's
investor meaning
a lot of young gen z millennials are all
right they keep calling them out yeah
they
they're all about the bitcoin or the
meme stuff when i interviewed him he did
not hold back from calling him out so
um you know it's funny a lot of that
criticism came before the bitcoin and
crypto crash
you know a few months ago because
crypto's gone and the specific argument
is you you haven't outperformed s p 500
last 15 years so it's not even a bitcoin
thing sure yeah
it's you haven't beaten s p 500. how
does hanging within damage and sue make
you hip
i think it was a nebraska connection i
think you hit the nail on the head
i think to wrap this all up to tie it
over to you if you have the opportunity
to shadow warren buffett
you go freaking do that boom bottom line
i mean
so i think look to get a little you know
sportsy here
you know a large percentage of nfl
players go straight up broke within
three to five years retirement i think
of nba players go broke within five
years of retirement
so if this is what it takes to basically
say hey look i'm playing in the nfl
and i shadowed freaking warren buffett
one of the greatest investors
of all time great arguably the greatest
investor of all time
let me take some of these examples let
me take some of these lessons bring it
to the field
what does warren buffett do for fun like
did he ever buy
i think he orders two egg mcmuffins
instead of one can you put kai
that's a big day for what does warren
buffett do for a fun what does warren
buffett do for
i think he actually has fun just doing
investing i know he doesn't
know i think he loves the game i don't
think he's like wakeboarding on that go
go on here let's find out tony go go on
warren buffett's favorite hobby if you
go down there well you saw one go back
go back kai go back
top thing warren buffett's favorite
hobby
reading while reading in terms of warren
buffett's approach investing it's a
hobby that you generally enjoy okay go
back to the 25 things you don't know
about warren buffett let's see
if we first stock he bought he was 11.
keep going
go up okay first talking about he was 11
years old he made 53 000
by the age of 16. by the way that's in a
different era
he was rejected by harvard business
school interesting okay keep going
see what number four is we're looking
for fun going
little faster guy he it's like a
six-year-old
he lived in the same house since 1958
his father-in-law told him cannot read
that guy
his father-in-law told him his
father-in-law told him he would fail
nice that's always a good motivator
people will pay millions to have lunch
with them
true somebody paid 4.57 million dollars
like a couple years ago
in 2013 buffett earned 37 million
dollars a day
rough nearly 94 of his wealth was earned
after he turned 60 big motivator never
give up keep going
wow number 10 uh uh he never tweeted
before
he's never tweeted before that's cool
keep going
uh 11 buffett owns 20 suits but has
never paid for any
he steals him he spends 80 of his day
reading
fantastic uh buffett will give an
employee a million dollars every year
for the rest of his life
his or her life if they can guess the
ncaa sweet 16 teams that's pretty fast
there's a hobby right there he likes
march madness that's right that's a good
point that's a good thing right there he
ditched his flip phone for an iphone in
2020 20
20. he takes a dozen kids to dairy queen
every sunday
wow i said no that's cool buffett rarely
emails
okay keep going 17 he plays
ukulele buffett pledged to donate 85
percent of his berkshire berkshire
hathaway stock to charitable foundations
okay
he was the one olympics he was the
awarded the presidential medal of
freedom by barack obama out of all
investing legends buffett has the same
best track record for beating the market
impressive his face was on cherry coke
cans in china in china okay
he doesn't follow anyone on twitter he's
a big fan of breaking bad
wow that's a good look keep going is
that him well what is that that's
actually him
that's actually the coolest picture i've
ever seen that's actually coolest
picture
he likes to joke around okay we know
that he looks to a poem
when markets decline no one can tell you
when those will happen more than others
i'm going to extraordinary opportunities
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs
when all about you are losing theirs if
you can wait
and not be tired of waiting if you can
think and not make thoughts your aim
if you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you yours
is the earth and everything that's in it
okay
all right cool do we have another one or
two can i can i make it here's how your
mind can play tricks on you and your
eyes if you go
go back to that list kai go back to the
very bottom of it go back to number 25
take a quick glance at number 25 and
then look away i literally when i first
saw that i thought he looks to porn i
thought that's what it said he looks
important i'm going
to while he's on time this morning good
for you i was saying is that your
business insider does their stories they
wait for number 25
so when tom zenner spent time with him
he noticed how much point he was
that probably would his three i got to
tell you when i hung out with warren
buffett all we did was watch porn
that's all we did i can actually see you
doing that pat was wondering what he
does for fun i don't know there we go
okay
all right so yeah so you can leave
ukulele
we have planned to learn what's that he
plays bridge though
good for him he doesn't play back i mean
nothing makes you seem more out of touch
you hang out with in dominican too i
mean that's all you need to know
there's like 200 i feel like that's in
touch you're hanging with okay
so let's continue so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye